[Music]
all season long we're highlighting home
towns all across the country because
there's no place like home
next up is seattle washington where
marley and anthony love call home
the loves love seattle and i have a
feeling we're about to also watch this
[Music]
hey drew it's anthony and marley and
we're in front of pike place market
located in our hometown of seattle
washington drew we love seattle so much
not just because of the great scenery
and great coffee but there's some places
that mean so much to us personally so
come with us and let us show you around
[Music]
we are at the iconic space needle a
signature staple for the seattle skyline
of course it's iconic but it's personal
for us because on our first trip to
seattle in 2015
this was the spot when we decided that
we were going to move to seattle and now
it just represents the love that we have
for this city
[Music]
welcome to boon buna coffee boon boona
is a local seattle coffee shop that
specializes in african coffee before
moving to seattle we only drank the name
brand stuff but locals told us hey you
have to try a local spot boom booner was
the first one and we fell in love now
that we got some coffee let us take you
to another spot that is personal to us
[Music]
we're from the alki beach one of many
beaches located right here in seattle
yeah there's so many beautiful beaches
in seattle you really can't go wrong but
aokai is our personal favorite not only
because it was the first beach that we
visited when we moved to seattle but
look at those breathtaking views
also visitors can play volleyball walk
run or ride on the paved path laid along
the beach on top of all that right
across from the beach are great options
for food and fun with plenty of
restaurants bars and shops alki beach
another reason why we love seattle
well drew that's just a snapshot of this
beautiful city of seattle we hope you
love it as much as we do we can't wait
for you to come visit see you soon
i love you loves and by the way i never
go to seattle without hitting pikes
market and having a bowl of the best
clam chowder ever
oh what a wonderful place i love seattle
and hometowns and i love this country
[Music]
you